لقد سمع الجميع عن metaverse
ولكن تقريبًا لا أحد يعرف ما هو أو
ما يمكن أن يكون يومًا ما ، لذلك دعونا نساعد في
تغيير أن metaverse هو رؤية
لمستقبل الإنترنت ، ورؤية
لإنترنت ثلاثي الأبعاد غامر ربما يمزج بين
الواقع المادي والواقع الافتراضي
رواة القصص الخيال العلمي  لقد تخيلت
هذا لعقود من الزمن في الواقع ،
تم صياغة كلمة metaverse لأول مرة في عام 1992
ولكن الآن بعض أكبر الشركات
في العالم مثل facebook تعيد تشكيل
نفسها وتستثمر المليارات في
هذه الرؤية
بعد أن أعاد مارك زوكربيرج تسمية
شركته meta لتعكس هذا الواقع
ماثيو  كان الكرة يكتب عن
metaverse منذ بداية المفهوم الحديث ،
فهو الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة epilon ، وهو
مؤلف الكتاب الجديد ،
وكيف سيحدث ثورة في العالم ،
لذا أخبرنا ماثيو أنه يمكننا البدء
بما هو metaverse ليس قد يكون
أسهل  اشرح الأمر بهذه الطريقة ،
فأنت على حق تمامًا لأن المصطلح قد
ارتفع في الارتباك الشعبي
وانتشر الارتباك
الاستعارات ليست
تشفيرًا ولا بلوكشين ، وقد تكون هذه
تقنيات ذات صلة أو
فلسفات على نطاق أوسع ولكنها منفصلة
عن metaverse نفسها والتي تعكس
كما ذكرت نسخة ثلاثية الأبعاد من
الإنترنت ، مستوى متوازي من
الوجود لا يحل metaverse محل كل شيء
نحن في عصر الأجهزة المحمولة والسحابة ،
وما زلنا نستخدم التخزين المحلي ، فأنا على
جهاز كمبيوتر شخصي في الوقت الحالي ،
ولا يعد metaverse عبارة عن محاكاة لألعاب فيديو ثلاثية الأبعاد
يتم التعبير عنها بشكل أفضل في
الترفيه ولكن هذا اليوم بسبب
محدودية هذه المحاكاة بالنسبة  أكثر من ذلك بكثير
نراه الآن في
الرعاية الصحية للتعليم الصناعي وأكثر من
ذلك في المستقبل قد أتمكن من الذهاب
إلى مدينة ملاهي في metaverse ولكن
الأهم من ذلك أنني قد أتمكن من
زيارة طبيبي
الذي سيكون جزءًا منه ولكن  أود أن
أخبرك أنه يمكنك بالفعل في أكتوبر أن
تجري جامعة جونز هوبكنز
أول جراحة حية على الإطلاق للمريض باستخدام
جهاز الواقع المختلط
عندما تمشي عبر طيران هونغ كونغ
الدولي  المنفذ الذي يتم إعادة إنتاجه
مباشرة في محاكاة ثلاثية الأبعاد ويستخدم المشغل
ذلك لتحديد البوابة
وأي طائرة يتم استخدامها ولماذا ،
لذلك يوجد بالفعل هنا من بعض النواحي ما
هي علامة zuckerbergs في العالم التي
تحاول القيام بوسائط disney وكذلك
الوسائط الرئيسية  تستثمر الشركات
في هذا الأمر ، لكن ما يعملون بالفعل
على
طريقة جيدة للتفكير في هذا هو
طرح السؤال عما تطلبه
لجهاز iPhone ، وكان الكثير من هذا هو
أجهزة واجهة المستخدم
التي كانت شركة Apple رائدة في معظمها ولكن
الكثير منها  كان في
البنية التحتية للاتصالات السلكية واللاسلكية في التقنيات الأساسية
التي تسمح لنا بتبادل
المعلومات من آلاف الأميال
والشبكات المختلفة بعيدًا ، ولم يتم تصميم أي من هذا
لثلاثة أبعاد ، صحيح أنني
كنت أفكر في الحكومة الأمريكية
الأسبوع الماضي قائلًا إننا سنعمل على رفع مستوى
النطاق العريض بحيث
لا يعتبر الإنترنت البطيء نطاقًا عريضًا بعد
الآن وسنضطر إلى الاستمرار في القيام بذلك
كدولة وكعالم لخلق
جودة أعلى  اتصالات من أجل
تمكين إنترنت ثلاثي الأبعاد هو هذا صحيح
تمامًا وبسرعة كما بدأت
أكبر شركات التكنولوجيا على وجه الأرض في
التمحور إلى
المنظمات الوطنية metaverse وكذلك
تحالف metaverse الكوري الجنوبي الذي تم تشكيله من قبل
قسم المعلومات والاتصالات
والتكنولوجيا الذي توحد  يقال إن 450
شركة من مصنعي الثلاجات إلى
المركبات والبنوك
كلها لبناء خدمة وطنية ،
تتطلع روسيا الآن إلى بناء
خدمة محاكاة ثلاثية الأبعاد وطنية خاصة بها
لأن كل ما
يستخدمونه الآن يأتي منا ،
لذا دعونا نحاول معرفة الكثير من هذا
لا يمكن التنبؤ بها وهذه واحدة من
النقاط التي تضعها في كتابك الكثير من
هذا المستقبل لا يمكن التنبؤ به ولكن
هل يمكننا تخيل نسخة من cnn في 10
سنوات هل يمكنك أن تخبرنا كيف ستكون هذه المقابلة
مختلفة في 10 سنوات
بشكل جيد أعتقد أنه يمكننا تخيل ذلك
يمكن أن يكون جمهور الاستوديو غير محدود ، ليس فقط
زملائك بالتأكيد كان جون
كينج يبتكر عندما يتعلق الأمر بالبيانات
عرض تقديمي قدرة
الجمهور على الشعور
كما لو كانوا في المزيج ، سنبدأ
في رؤية ذلك وبصراحة
سيتمكن الجمهور في المنزل من تشغيل وإيقاف
ما يريدون لمس الشاشة بدلاً
من أن يأمل جون